britney spears's dad is speaking out
after being suspended as a conservator
of her estate
[Applause]
e.t was outside the l.a courthouse on
wednesday when the judge agreed to
suspend britney's dad jamie spears from
overseeing her fortune and career
[Applause]
now jamie is responding to the ruling in
a statement from his attorneys that read
in part quote mr spears loves his
daughter brittany unconditionally for 13
years he has tried to do what is in her
best interests whether as a conservator
or her father
the statement continues citing jaime's
role in helping her revive her career
and re-establish a relationship with her
children sixteen-year-old shawn preston
and fifteen-year-old jaden james whom
she shares with her ex kevin fetterline
quote for anyone who has tried to help a
family member dealing with mental health
issues they can appreciate the
tremendous amount of daily worry and
work this required now despite the
suspension jaime says he will quote
continue to look out for the best
interests of his daughter and work in
good faith towards a positive resolution
of all matters
[Applause]
[Music]
brittany made headlines earlier this
year when she gave an explosive
testimony at a hearing sharing a slew of
shocking allegations against her father
and her team following her claims
jamie's attorney said in a statement to
the judge at the time quote he is sorry
to see his daughter suffering and in so
much pain mr spears loves his daughter
and misses her very much
i'm so pleased and proud to say
jamie spears
is no longer a conservator and while
jamie's official removal will be decided
at a later hearing the pop star's
attorney told et on wednesday that she
is happy with the judge's most recent
decision and the future is bright
where do you see britney's life going
from here as she talked about what she
might want to do when this is over in a
month if hopefully she's got a great
future ahead of her
after the hearing brittany posted this
video from the cockpit of a plane to
instagram alongside the caption quote on
cloud nine right now
britney spears has been faced
with a decade-long nightmare a
kafka-esque nightmare orchestrated by
her father
and others
and i'm so proud of her
for her courage
her strength
and her poignancy and i've only been on
this matter for a couple of months but
i'm proud to say that we've gotten to
know each other
very well
and she's so pleased and she's so
thankful to all of you
[Music]
you